everybody's always trying to kick your
ass and you have to figure out how to
kick your out your own ass first
I was fanatical in my 20s
helping Microsoft lead the way in
software was the only thing that I
really focused on the way I tend to view
problems this is from it from a physics
standpoint wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
solo and I believe life for
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to think
and act like a billionaire okay let's
take it off with rule number one be
brutally honest with yourself with Mark
Cuban even after you had done your thing
there was still an eight-course to make
sure that yahoo itself was on tracked
you know what that was about
yeah they were screwing everything up
you know I mean look they had they had
an opportunity to dominate streaming
media they also own at the same time the
patent to cost-per-click yeah right now
Google's entire business to this day is
build around pay-per-click well they're
not calling create Oh click yeah so they
had the entire patent for pay-per-click
had they just said sorry Google you
can't use it there would be no Google
instead they said you have 133 million
dollars and give us some stock they were
just too nice right which blinded them
in a lot of respects and I remember
walking in with a thirty two million
dollar sale saying okay we're gonna do
streaming we're gonna sell all this
company's content you know it's worth
thirty two million dollars for us and
it's going to pre up these other
potential competitors and I forget if
it's Jerry or Tim or whoever said no we
don't work that way we don't pre up
competition and we just leave it open
okay it's time for me to go buy a
basketball team that's they just they
just didn't see these things then I mean
it's a lesson in your businesses there's
going to be everybody's always trying to
kick your ass and you have to figure out
how to kick your out your own ass first
seriously because if you're not brutally
honest with yourself in your own
business about what your frailties are
someone else is going to find them
Yahoo didn't get that Yahoo just thought
you know what we're just going to
continue moving forward and we'll just
compete with everybody else
you know there's we have no other
problems didn't quite work out for him
did it
rule number two use physics principles
in your thinking with Elon Musk the way
I tend to view problems this is from it
from a physics standpoint and I think I
think physics is a good analytical
framework and one of the key things in
physics is to reason from first
principles this is contrary to the way
most human reasoning takes place which
is by analogy reasoning from first
principles just means that you figure
out what are the fundamentals what are
the fundamental truths or or things that
are pretty people are pretty sure of
fundamental truths and and can you build
up to a conclusion front from that or
you know from those principles and and
then certainly if you come up with some
idea and it appears to violate one of
those fundamental truths and you're
probably wrong or you should get a
really big prize or something like that
so this may seem like I don't know maybe
it may seem sort of obvious when it's
explained but it's actually not what
people do you reasoning my analogies is
helpful because it's a shortcut yeah
and and it's mostly correct but but it
tends to be most incorrect when you're
dealing with new things because it's
hard to analogize to something really
new rule number three be obsessed with
Bill Gates your early days he described
yourself as a nightmare boss visit your
words not mine and was your worth work
ethic just very different to everybody
else's I was fanatical in my 20s
helping Microsoft lead the way in
software was the only thing that I
really focused on so you know I worked
weekends I didn't believe in vacation
and so I I really pushed people to work
hard
teach and I was still learning how to
manage people particularly the different
skill sets the salespeople the
accounting people and so you know I I I
fortunately I think I'm a little bit
better now also if you want to have more
self love and confidence check out my
254 series they're free the link to join
our
if everything has to work in two to
three years then that limits what you
can do I've always been passionate some
people thought you know it's a it's more
OCD than anything else when I was
selling copiers door-to-door I had a
very clear vision of what my life was
gonna be like rule number four persevere
with Jeff Bezos your stock at one point
I think went to hundred dollars but then
I went down to six or something like
that
at the peak of the internet bubble our
stock peaked some around a hundred and
thirteen dollars and then after the
internet bubble you know busted open our
stock went down to six
it went from a hundred and thirteen to
six in less than a year my annual
shareholder that year starts with a one
word sentence and that one word sentence
is the word ouch so most of those
internet companies of the dot-com era
are out of business
yeah you survived what was that that
made you to survive and virtually the
rest of them are gone oh it's true the
whole period is very interesting because
the stock is not the company and the
company is not the stock and so as I
watched the stock fall from 113 to six I
was also watching all of our internal
business metrics number of customers
profit per unit you know everything you
can imagine defects etc every single
thing about the business was getting
better and fast and so as the stock
price was going the wrong way
everything inside the company was going
the right way and I you know so I wasn't
we didn't need to go back to the capital
markets we didn't need more money the
only reason you know financial bust like
the internet bubble bursting is you know
it makes it really hard to raise money
but you know we already had the money we
needed so we just needed to continue to
progress rule number five use humor to
your advantage was Sara Blakely I know
that as part of the Spanx training boot
camp one of the mandatory learning
modules is comedy that every employee
has to go through so why is that
important I didn't understand why why
everybody was so serious so I thought
you know what I don't subscribe to the
fact that you have to act serious to be
taken seriously and I like to laugh at
myself I you know I looked when I
worked in corporate America for a long
time and everybody was super uptight and
super serious there was no humor and
there was no levity and then everybody
at like 5:00 o'clock became ragingly
hilarious like what what's going on like
you know and so the alcohol probably
helped you know but but anyway I I
wanted to to use humor and I love to do
that in the workplace and yes we have a
boot camp at Spanx a training boot camp
when you come on board and one of the
modules is doing stand-up comedy and
I've used the comedic stuff that I did
in my marketing I mean I wrote don't
worry we've got your butt covered right
on my package when I first started in
2000 which was not very common to do
especially taking it to the
neiman-marcus to sell it I named my
company Spanx which was you know made
people laugh and believe it or not it
was very shocking at the time that I
named the company Spanx that actually
had people hang up on me often I would
call them and say hi I'm Sara from Spanx
and then they'd hang up and I'd call
back and I go I'm serious I'm a real
company and my company's called spinning
and they go oh oh I thought you were
prank calling me so and then you know
naming my products I broke into the
world's most boring category I mean can
we talk about shapewear who wants to
talk about shapewear and undergarments
but it was I named it power panties you
know I started naming all my products
and it made people laugh and it gave so
much energy and then all of a sudden you
had Gwyneth Paltrow and Julia Roberts
flashing their Spanx on red carpets and
saying I'm wearing Spanx like all these
celebrities and I think it's because I
chose to do humor and people wanted to
participate in that there was energy
around that so so I use it in in every
aspect of the marketing I use humor to
turn around a situation when I'm bombing
and it might give me a second chance
when I cold called
to sell fax machines door-to-door for
seven years I learned very quickly that
if I could make somebody laugh or smile
I'd get another 30 seconds before they'd
slam the door in my face there's just
it's helps you move through pain it's
it's it's a wonderful tool and rule
number six the last one before a very
special bonus clip is make mistakes with
Mark Zuckerberg so many things go wrong
when you're starting a company and often
I think people ask
you know what mistakes should you avoid
making and you know my answer that
question is don't even bother trying to
avoid mistakes because you're gonna make
tons of mistakes right and the the
important thing is actually learning
quickly from whatever mistakes you make
and not giving up right and I mean there
are things every single year of
Facebook's existence that could have
killed us or made it so that it just
seemed like moving forward and making a
lot of progress just seemed intractable
but you just kind of bounce back and you
learn and nothing is impossible you just
have to kind of keep running through the
walls now I have a special bonus clip
from Robert Smith on how to take risks
that I think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go
question number one where do you need to
be more brutally honest with yourself
number two how can you use humor to your
advantage and number three where do you
need to just persevere and if you made
it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you give me a hashtag believe
down the comments as well you're doing
very well out there you're now living in
San Francisco area you're making a big
success you by investment-banking
standards I presume you're you know
highly compensated so forth what
propelled you to say I'm gonna give all
this up and go start my own company
right so the interesting thing that
occurred as you know again as an
engineer that I realized way back in my
Goodyear entire in rubber days the
impact that software really had on
businesses the thing that I noticed that
there's very few software companies were
actually efficiently run well why the
big part was most executives who started
software companies well they wrote code
or they knew a market opportunity and
they sold the code there was never
anyone who taught them how to run
software companies so I didn't run into
this the small company I'll say small in
Houston Texas that is the most efficient
software company I've ever seen
they had some very basic things that
they just did extremely well and I said
well if you took those basic things and
actually applied them ultimately to
other enterprise software companies you
could run those businesses very similar
to the way they ran theirs and would
create tremendous value in those
companies that that was the idea that
was a conceit and they said that's a
good idea why don't you do it well yeah
in essence I said well if you actually
thought about taking
some of these best practices and putting
him buying enterprise software companies
and driving them forward you could
actually do pretty well and I said
that's a great idea would you do that
and I said well you know they gave me
one of those offers that looked quite
interesting and I remember my lawyer
said this is a bad deal Robert but you
should take it yeah right so you went to
Goldman and said I'm leaving right did
they try to talk you out of it of course
they made the pitch against it but you
know I like all things David at some
point in time in your life you know you
got to look yourself in the mirror and
said you know you have to take a little
risk and go see if this is how old were
you when you took this I was 39 years
old and I so you're so interesting so of
course I started doing research it was
the same age that others left what they
were doing to go start their businesses
I said well let's go give it a run
if you want to know why your comfort
zone is destroying your life check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
it whenever you find things that you're
comfortable doing you're going away from
the journey of life
good people often become seduced by the
chatter